bu
helvayı ların resmi var sayılarını
geçirdim
başta Şanlıurfa gelene kadar bütün
konuşmacıların insanlar çok büyük saygı
duyuyorum ben Zeynep genç yaşta burada
olmak için yapmayacağım bir
şey
heyecandan lütfen içinden Kusura
bakmayın şimdi gümüşhanelilere sorarlar
müzik açımız çocukluktan başladı diye
tarihin mikrofon yapardım ayrı konser
verdim falan bir
şeyler Başlamak isterim ki Sonuçta bir
çektiği şey sahibi bir sebebi vardır
oyuncak bebeklere elbise diken ablalarla
birlikte büyüdüm şimdi babalardan
biriyle bağışlandı markasıyla birlikte
ter döküyoruz ama üç buçukta kitabımızın
da bir gerçekten değişmedi bir sorun
hepsini ama bacaklarını ama olarak aile
bu
İddaa Erdoğan'ın tarihi Evet bence ancak
Şener atölyesinde bulunabilirdi Şimşek
madamlar vs doğal bir süreç işledi anne
gülüş ablam ardından mesaj ablam pek
selamın o tasarımı eğitimi olarak
değerlerine başladılar şimdi yaşında bir
yeğenim var istemeyiz ve güvenlik ve bir
araya geldiğimizde dışarı çıkacağım O
zaman bir ses Yaklaşık bir saat
arasından Osman çekiliyor gerçekten
inanmazsınız ama çorabından unuttun O
gün takıya pazara kadar Bize yaklaşık
4-5 tane bir kombin oluşturuyor ve
milletiyle yapıyor Armağan pirimiz
oluyor dışarı çıkarken hangisini
giymeliyiz sizi de ama bilirsiniz
çocuklar her zaman biraz daha kendi
İstediklerini yapmak isterler bizim
fikrimiz nasıl odasına gittiğinde
bambaşka bir kombin hepsini yanına
giderim sonra dışarıya çıkarız Yani
burada söylemek istediğim Aslında
yediden yetmişe tam olarak ailede
hepimiz moda ilgileniyoruz o
sırada servisi kariyeri çok güzel
videolar şu Nişantaşı'nda Ağla Caddesi
ve çevresi basini saatleri İzmir Ankara
Bursa semtleri tırnak içerisinde
sorduğum gerçekten tasarımcı olan kadın
sayısı sanırım olmayan daha fazladır
yırtmak için söylemek istiyorum şu an
sosyal medyada hepimizin gördüğü birkaç
kombin yapan Instagram'da filosunun
tasarımcı kimliğinin farkında eklenen
birçok Aslı çevremizde insan var şimdi
bu kadınlar tarafından zevkle takdir
görürler ardından kendine bir online
mağaza açarlar bir detay lan siz
öncesinde tane kapatırlar Yaklaşık 16 ay
sonra dikenleri online mağaza açarlar
vesaire vesaire ama sonuç olarak
herkesin kendisini kolayca aygördü
birinin için yüzyıllarda okuyoruz cizim
masalarından İş makinalarında skolyoz
başlangıcı karşısındaki Bu süreçten
bahsediyorum size bileceksin moda
haftalarına gelişmelerini takip
edeceksin her gün yeni baştan Özgün
kriteri kullanılabilir ve bir gün önce
bu dünyada olmayan parçaları hayata
geçireceksin ve hop yan tarafta yeni bir
buçuk açılmış yenibirmeslek başlatılmış
Aramızda ama Telaşa gerek yok çünkü
birazdan yenisi gelecek var Bundan hemen
sonra kiralık yapısını Göreceğiz şimdi
hayatımda kırılma noktalarında
levhalardan bir Çanakkale işaret
ediyordu aşağıya bir öğrenciydim
araştırma yapmayı çok seviyorum öder
Samet benim için çok yazık geliyordu Ben
Onsekiz Mart Üniversitesi Tekstil ve
moda tasarımı bölümü başlatan Barbie
sonunda markası resmi çalıyor ve suyumuz
olduğunu gayet ol tarafından kuruldu
anne tabi bütün Boş vakitlerimde
bu süre zarfında 2016 bakayım da en
altındakine yapmamız gerek kabul
edilmiştir ve okunmaması sesi hazırlanın
içerisinde olmak hem iyi hem de o kadar
çok zor ki anlatamam sizin sıkılmış
orada yapalım Önce zaten buradakiler hiç
nişan ünlüler işi mutfağımız nasıl bir
gidek olduğunuzu Aynı hızda karışır
sebep oluyordu işin içine girdiği
tanıyormuş işin içine girince aldım en
önemli derslerden biri de hava aldığını
yapmadım işim patronun yapmanın imkansız
oluyor şimdi böyle geçiren konusu
saatlerde bahsediyoruz Onun için
yurtdışına başına 150 pilot bavullar
ünlüler bir ajansları hasta iki dansları
satın almacılar basın ve son dakika
hepinize gelmeyen modeller tatlı etmez
bizden bunları yaşıyoruz
belki de tüm dünya odası hakim buralar
bir kitlenin önüne tasarımlarını
çıkarmak gelecek eleştiriler A101
olduğunun onaylanması ya da
onaylanmaması çünkü kopya acılığı
kaldırabilecek bir daha sonra değilsiniz
Ama haklısın bahsettiğini
3D burada
ben Kaya kırılma noktalarını birkaç
sorun olduğunu düşünüyorum mesela
balıkların Hint toplumunu yüzükleri
bilmemeleri şimdi yanlışlık sorma
atölyede siniz Sizin gördüğünüz o harika
falan çıkan kalk sesler
böyle giriyorsunuz az bir takım ise terk
ustalardan yediniz fırçalar oluyor ve
çalıyor diyorsunuz bir bırakmış yere en
başında bahsettiğim o
tasarımcı kimliğinin çok kolay üzerine
alınan insan var dedim ya bazen onlardan
alıp olmak zorunda kalıyorsunuz bir
eğitimi almış tasarımcı olarak size
işiniz öğretmeyi kalabiliyorlar biraz
sinirliyiz bozulabiliyor onlar
ilgileniyorsunuz var Onları gördüm Ne
diyorsunuz ve arka taraf atölye
geçtiğimiz zaman ablanızdan yanan
fırçalar var Bu sırada hakkında En
azından ya Parçalar oluyor bu süre
zarfında bana
arkasının tekrar aynı şeyleri yaşıyorum
yardım tekrar aynı şeyleri yaşamak
inanmazsınız ama Pazar günü gerçekten
tam anlamıyla yataktan dışarı çıkmak
istemiyordum Pazartesi tekrar aynı
şeyleri yaşıyoruz bu süre zarfında
happier Tamam azcık eksiklik işi Yapı
içerisinde kapatıyorsunuz
ve kadar kırılma noktalarında bu süre
zarfında dondurma daha fazla hepinizi
ölçülü sevgilerimizi yapmıştık yeni
sayısız ünlü ismini tarifim olmuş kişi
pazar yerlerinde satılmaya başlamış ama
artık hızla yükselmekte de bu noktada
iken de ya helal kırılma noktalarında
iki sonrasında devreye giriyor kontrol
alanını terk etmek Ben hayatımdaki en
önemli
nokta mı pompalımı Terk etmeye karar
vermekte yaptım tanıtımı araştır bir
insanım Neyse Çanakkale'de okumuşum hiç
ayrılmak istemiyorum ve en ufak bir
planımız da Çanakkale'ye konuda teması
kurmak için elimden geleni yapıyorum
aslında ama bunun böyle olmayacağını
yerde anlamam gerekiyordu Ve o noktada
pompaların Terk etmeye karar vermek
zorunda kaldım sonunda değilim atabilir
seçiminizi yapmak yaptım pompanın fark
etti ve
İstanbul'a gittim dünya yaptırdım
gerçekten tam anlamıyla soruyoruz Dünyam
değişti iyisiyle kötüsüyle ama tam
anlamıyla Ben hayatımı iyisiyle
değiştirdi diyebilirim size bu süre
zarfında
İyi bari sondur şu anda
o kıza yerlerine satılmaya başlamış
sayısının ismini tercih olmuş kuruluştan
verip liderim olan ablan mesaj Aldırmaz
hem de şu anda Londra'da sabahlama bana
bir de bye semtinde Global Teknik
direktörümüz Ve artık onu çözdü
sorunlara ilişkin süreçleri kristal
içeri bir yer ama öte yandan ünlüler
satın almacılar
markanın parakende satış noktası gelişim
süreçleri tamamlamaya Hepsi benim önümde
sonra bambaşka bir boyutta aynı onlara
yolda dolaşmakta sayısız un görüşmeleri
sonra hemen
gelişmelerini farkedilmesi
o zaman ve gönlünde gördüm Günaydın
gönderdiğiniz ürünün son Anlaşılan
Lojistik sorunların çözülmesi tüm
milletin insanlarla uğraşma sanki House
duyuyor ve Ama iyi az önce de dediğim
gibi böyle bir yoldan tercih ettim ve
iyisiyle kötüsüyle
seçimleri bana ait
[Müzik]
bu
şöyle söylemek gerekirse
sürekli yeniliklere açık olmak
zorundasınız sürekli gelişmeleri takip
etmek zorundasınız işçi bilmek
zorundasınız Hacı tanımayı bilmek
zorundasınız malzeme tedarik
zincirlerinin bilmek zorundasınız ekşi
ve ekip yönetiminde bilmek zorundasınız
Tüm bunları Global ölçekte kavramayı
uygulamayı bilmek zorundasınız Yani
söylemek istedim yeniliklerle sürekli
işte olmak zorunda ve kendinizi
geliştirmek zorunda değil zor ve biz bu
noktada bir son bir yılda süpürülebilir
moda üzerine çalışıyordu hocam sonuçlara
ulaştık bir Tamam hepsi şeylerden
görüştüğümüz bir çocuk koleksiyon
hazırladık Babam istanbul'da birisiyle
tanıştık ardından yoga moda haftası'nda
ve Taylantlı hafta dijital olarak
sahipleri ve Gerçekten inanılmaz
sonuçlara ulaştık Şimdi de dünyayı
bulunduğumuz tüm Yalnızlığa yayınlarımız
da geri dönüştürülmüş materyallerden
ürettiğimiz ürünleri ortasında
çalışıyoruz bu işte Tam da bu noktada
bir yolu aynı anda yürümeyi Tercih
ettiğim görüşündeyim Zira alanına
Dünyası çok değişik atlarsan gelecek
şekilde kariyerinde ilerlemek ve tüm
öğrendiklerimi bir gün Onsekiz Mart
Üniversitesi mezun olduğu üniversiteden
öğrencilerine birlikte paylaşacağım
günleri sabırsızlıkla beklemekteyiz ayak
Bazen çok zor oradan çok güzel ama en
güzel de Çanakkale böyle bir buluşma
için gelmiş olmazsa teşekkür ediyorum o